Uh.. so yesterday I had to take my shirt off..
So brad did that. I don't know how, I haven't seen the footage yet
I'm wearing the shirt, okay, shut up! I'm so tired of all this "OH you're not wearing the (inaudible)"
Ever since I got to LA I've been so busy, I've just been doing so much!
Everyone wants to meet, and it's really nice, and everyone want's to do stuff.
But I haven't had any time for myself, and it's just...
Do you ever feel like, when that happens to you, you're just going crazy?
I don't know, what do you think, Garbles?
"In my honest opinion I'm afraid you're being a little bitch."
Yeah. Yeah, I kinda agree.
So I'm going to the gym now, THANK FUCKING GOD, finally!
If you ever.. If you work out, and you don't get to do it, I go fucking crazy.
I just wanna fucking punch someone in the fucking...
OH MY GOD, I'm so sorry! I'm so sorry!
Alright I think that was the most amount of times someone has ever said "bro" to me.
But it was cool.
Parking in this place... is two and a half dollar.. per fifty minutes.
That's fucking CRAZY.
I'm outta here!
Wait, alright, so I calculated. That's $250...
*loud sirens in background* Okay, I'm dying.
$250 FOR A DAY??? LA, WHAT THE FUCK IS WRONG WITH YOU???
K, I'm gonna stop vlogging.
GARBLE IS TRIGGERED.
Ugh, I feel a LOT better.
I feel so much better having gone to the gym now.
I keep driving on the wrong side of the road! Just now, I was like,
Why is that woman driving straight towards me? What the fuck is her problem? Oh wait, I am on (laughs)
It's a miracle we haven't crashed yet, Let's just say that.
So now we're gonna go out, find another present for Michael, that spoiled SON OF A BITCH!
I keep reading all of the comments on the first video. I'm really taking them to heart because I..
I spent like a week trying to prepare for these vlogs, which I know isn't like a huge amount of time
but considering we do daily videos, I wanted it to work out!
And, it seems like you guys are liking it. (we are pewds!)
It's also fun for me to feel really invested in something, doing something different.
And I apprecaite all the feedback, and all the Constructive Criticism that helps me grow!
Did I just Heil..? I think I just....
It's a good thing this camera zooms in way too much *laugh*
Marzia: We're here to get a gift!
We are in Santa Monica!
Brad: Wait, didn't we buy a gift for Michael already?
Yeah, but we have to get another gift for Michael or he'll be like "UGH you just got me a printer? ugh!"
Everyone loves Michael in the vlogs, and it bothers me so much. "Why don't you love me?" *laughs* (we love you too Brad)
Stop! Stop, film me, this is my vlog! People are here to see me, not girls.
Oh my god, where's your shirt?
.... Oh.
You ripped it up? Brad: So I made it, all kind of like, ripped cool.
Pewds: To (inaudible) the nipple! Brad: Yeah. *laughs* It kinda, almost works. It's still bad.
But, it almost looks like it was kinda meant to be.
Pewds: It's not bad.
Brad: It was the only way to do it. Pewds: It's the only way... It's pretty clever. Dammit.
I think it's going to come to a point where we start doing really bad shit to them... Brad: Yeah.
(Awkward....)
For Michael, because he always wears the same one. Now he won't look like shit!
Michael is always like "Oh, I want to take physical pictures!"
But you don't have any friends Michael...
Brad: So we get him, this?  Pewds: And we put it in the frame! It's perfect!
Brad: so we take a picture of us? Pewds: Yeah, and we put it in the frame! And we print it!
Brad: So we did need the printer? *Pewds laughs* Welllll....
Let's get him this.
Alright, we're heading back. I bought gifts for Michael, and, uh, he better like them!
That's all I'm gonna say.
I'm really tired... it's a tough life to live... spending money... *laughs*
Brad: 'scuse me? 'SCUSE ME? Can I get in the car?
Brad: Can you give me a ride? 'SCUSE ME? Can you give me a ride?
Pewds: Okay, okay, I open. One second senor... *drives off*
When I was 14, there was this DJ, called DJ adolf, which would just sample all his Hitler mixes,
and it was the best shit, and I would play it, uh, I would play it at my house, and then a neighbor heard it
And they came over.. and they yelled at me...
Ugh! We're stuck in traffic. Hey Garbo, could you play us some music?
* spanish music ensues* AWWW YEAHHHH
And we're movin!  Brad: It worked! well done Garbo!
Pewds: Thank you Garbo!
*spanish music continues*
Turn that shit up!
*SPANISH MUSIC INTENSIFIES*
"HERE IS THE ACTUAL US BOMBING OF THE  MIGHTY USS ARIZONA BY JAP PLANE!"
Brad: snap out of it!
*spanish music continues*
What happened to you? It was weird. You started like, swerving all over the place.
Wait, what happened?
It's been like... Pewds: where am I?   Brad: It's been six weeks. You were in a coma.... for 6 weeks.
I remember the coma, I remember every day... They would feed me through a tube. (aww)
Okay, we're doing a picture for Michael.
Three... Two... One...
This is never gonna work. I am gonna be surprised if this works.
That.. that looks so good!
We got a card... Yeah... And we're gonna write a special message.
Pewds: special message for Michael. Brad: Yeah.
Happy birthday tooo Michaellll, Happy birthday toooo Michaelllll
Michael, you come in here!
HAPPY BIRTHDAYYY TO YOUUUU!
Michael: Thank you, woo!
Garbo, don't be sad, we're coming back for you... JUST KIDDING! FAST, FAST BEFORE HE CAN RUN AWAY
GET IN THE CAR....
Hey look at Michael! Everyone is saying you're so cute. Michael: ayy! ahhh birthday!
Pewds: NO! I mean, only on your birthday! Michael: I am so cute! (yes you are, Michael)
Fine, it's your birthday. Fine.
Michael, happy birthday! I'm not a speech person, oh yes I am!
Michael, you're the worst person.. I have ever met.. A lot of times I just dread the fact that you are part of my life.
and how we ended up like this..
But you are also a very kind person, you're very sweet. Michael: and very cute!
And apparently very cute! A lot of people think Michael is very cute. I'm really glad you're here salawing...
Celebrating a birthday. Michael: YEAH! Thank you! Pewds: And let's just drink this damn sake!
Brad and Pewds: Happy birthday Michael! (aww so cute)
Marzia: It's time to open the gift!
Michael: For my wife...
Pewds: That's how we see you, Michael. The wife we never wanted
Michael, you always say 'uhh, i want to have..
Michael: wuttt
Pewds: 'I want to have memories that are physical 'cuz in this modern day and age.. I want a camera.' So there you go!
Michael: Aww, we need to try it out!
Pewds: And, you also have friends now! We took a picture for you.  Michael: awww!
Michael:Where is Brad? Oh.. Oh wait look! Brad (something something)!
Michael:Thank you very much! I wanted to buy one..
Pewds: I know, because you were talking about it. Michael: Yeah.
Brad: NOW KISS! Kiss him! (DO IT PEWDS)
Michael: It's my birth... Pewds: EW.
Michael: Do it, do it. Pewds: I can't even go close. I can't even fake it.
Michael: That's my wish! Brad: That's his birthday wish, you have to give him a kiss on the cheek
Pewds: What the hell is the matter with you?
Marzia: On the cheek! Pewds: No, it's disgusting!      Brad: It's his birthday.
Michael: For all the harrassment...
Pewds: Fuck you, alright, you fuckin' bitch             Michael: noo
Alright, day 3 of Birdabo, did anyone get a strike? DID ANYONE GET A STRIKE? Brad: you!
No I... Okay, maybe I got one. Whatever.
Uhhh
Alright, leave a like if you enjoyed, 'preciate that you guys are showing so much support for the birdabo!
And I'll see you.... IN THE NEXT EPISODE! (of Birdabo)
#michaeliscute